hi it's giannis pappas of the bay ridge
boys history hyenas podcast
and here are some tips for those people
who are worried about their family
members
if trump or biden wins don't worry
if donald trump wins you can still be a
white celebrity
and live in a gated mansion as far away
from black people as possible
while simultaneously telling us their
life matters
if joe biden wins
don't worry we can get right back
to getting involved in the middle east
send troops back
and bomb the [ __ ] out of innocent people
don't worry
if donald trump wins you're still living
in america you can get
meat for a dollar don't worry if joe
biden wins
the 2 for 20 menu at applebee's is still
in full effect
you fat [ __ ] american circle
stay away from rooftops so you don't
cause a solar eclipse
don't worry if donald trump wins chelsea
handler will still be here to put voting
stickers on her tits
and tell you every single day that she
loves black [ __ ]
if donald trump wins tick-tock will
still be there for anyone over 40
who wants to scroll at night sleeping
next to their wife and look at 15 year
old girls and white air force ones doing
the dougie
and if joe biden wins
don't worry if joe biden wins we'll all
live to see the first
female president and she won't be
hillary wang
and finally if neither candidate wins
because the election is contested
which spawns a civil war and a dictator
comes to power
hey well at least russia and the chinese
can't meddle in our elections anymore